[Music]
police are saying a murder and attempted
murder are
caught on camera the person recording
the alleged killer himself
it is a story you will only see here
first on 8 news now
the i-team obtained the evidence at the
center of the case
vanessa murphy now has a story that we
do want to warn you
this report does include disturbing
content
a walk to a man who appears to be
homeless and passed out on the sidewalk
an arm raised gun pointed and the
trigger pulled
the i-team is freezing the video before
the victim is shot
in the middle of the forehead this was
in the early morning hours of july 13th
then on july 15 just before midnight as
a 62-year-old man walks his dog he
describes a man dressed as a mummy
approaching him and shooting him in the
chest
two crime scenes two days apart both
locations near sahara and decatur in las
vegas
metro police call the first a murder the
victim
48 year old brent lloyd his body
discovered by a jogger
the second in attempted murder the
victim survived
and called 911 himself after he ran to
his nearby home
three months later he is recovering from
his injuries
investigators say surveillance video
helped them find their suspect by
tracking his path
twenty-one-year-old noah green lives in
a nearby apartment complex
on july 18 police say after he ran from
officers as they approached him they
found this gun on him
and this cell phone with only two videos
on it
these a detective testified in front of
the grand jury
he was shocked he said greene denied any
involvement in the crimes
when he showed green the videos he
didn't see any outward reaction
he said that's his phone but he didn't
know how the videos got there
his defense attorney is questioning his
mental status
referring to the arrest report police
noted he appeared to talk to himself
during surveillance detectives say
green's mother described him as a loner
and after he told police about a
girlfriend and they tried to find her
it appeared she didn't exist greene was
indicted by the grand jury
he faces seven charges and is currently
at the clark county detention center
held on no bail vanessa murphy
8 news now noah greene's next court
appearance is set for november 6.